celebrate 10 years of danganronpa
in despair
[Applause]
um testing testing mic jack one two
this is a test of the school broadcast
system
[Music]
three games in the deadly dankan rampa
series are coming to nintendo switch
[Music]
monokuma the self-proclaimed school
headmaster has trapped you
and other high school students in a game
of literal life and death
unfortunately the only way out of the
school and this lethal game
is to betray the other students and so
it begins a body has been discovered
when a student meets their demise a
class trial will take place to reveal
the culprit you're the culprit aren't
you
telling me i have no idea they've
probably moved the body there
use the evidence you've gathered to
refute contradictions and find the
guilty party
sneak attack
are you okay
plus the board game from duncan rampa v3
killing harmony has been expanded into a
standalone game
dankanrampa s ultimate summer camp an
all-star cast of characters from the
dankanrampa series will come together to
battle at a tropical resort
who's the strongest of them all in this
ultimate beach brawl
the four-game collection duncan rampa
decadence launches as a physical
exclusive on nintendo switch later this
year
all four games will also be individually
available on nintendo eshop